Hong Kong is 92% ethnically Chinese.
But stroll through the central business district
on any given Sunday and you wouldn’t know
it.
Thousands upon thousands of domestic helpers
socialize on cardboard scattered across parks,
walkways, and sidewalks on their one and only
day off.
55% are from the Philippines — and virtually
all, women.
A similar dynamic, but for men, plays out
on the high seas.
Filipinos make up 1.4% of the world’s population
but roughly 30% of the world’s shipping
crew.
Take a cruise, for instance, and there’s
a very good chance you’ll have a Filipino
maid, cook, or server.
It’s not just low-skill work, either.
One-fifth of California registered nurses
are from the Philippines, despite comprising
only 4% of its population.
On any given day, 10% of all living Filipinos
are employed overseas, 2.3 million of which
are temporary workers.
The reason may seem obvious: Money.
The average nurse can make fifteen times more
working abroad.
Even domestic helpers make far more than they
would at home.
But why the Philippines, specifically?
The country is neither the world’s largest,
fastest-growing, nor even poorest potential
source of labor.
Being the cheapest is a tough “competitive
advantage” to maintain in a world of seven
billion people.
There will always be someone, somewhere more
desperate.
And yet, the Philippines has remained the
world’s go-to source of labor for decades,
almost monopolizing entire industries.
So, what’s the real reason?
Sponsored by Brilliant.
Learn math, science, and computer science
the intuitive way with the link in the description.
In 1973, the Middle East went on strike, cutting
off the world’s supply of oil.
Between December 1973 and January 1974, the
global price of crude more than doubled, from
26 to $61 per barrel.
For the Philippines, which imported 80% of
its oil, this made a bad situation much worse.
The Marcos government was already busy fighting
a Communist rebellion, had declared martial
law, and was suffering a balance of trade
deficit when consumer prices went through
the roof, and unemployment soon followed.
But the rise in oil prices had a second unintended
consequence: the fundamental transformation
of the global shipping industry.
When the price of oil rose, demand for tankers
fell dramatically.
But because a ship ordered today is only actually
delivered years down the road, their supply
continued rising long after they were no longer
needed.
As you can see, demand per tanker fell for
roughly the next ten years.
And during this period of excess supply, shipping
became far less profitable.
To cut costs, companies increasingly began
registering their ships in “Flag of Convenience”
countries like Panama and Liberia, where they
could bypass national labor laws.
Unions negotiated jobs for Japanese, Norwegian,
and Greek captains, but the bottom ranks were
suddenly open to the world.
And who better to fill them than the masses
of recently unemployed Filipinos.
Shipping companies didn’t just get access
to a cheap, willing, and able workforce fluent
in English, the international language of
the sea, but also their favorite kind: temporary.
Migrant workers are a Capitalist’s vision
of globalization — perpetuating national
borders when convenient, bypassing them when
not.
By importing labor from abroad, you profit
from wage differentials between countries,
but don’t have to worry about anti-immigrant
backlash.
You can hire them as soon as you have a job
to be done, and fire them just as fast when
it’s over, with none of the annoying paperwork.
Virtually all the power in this relationship
lies with the employer, some of which even
take away the passports of their workers.
Until March of last year, for instance, domestic
helpers in Saudi Arabia needed their employer’s
permission to leave the country.
Needless to say, this serendipitous combination
of push — in the form of unemployment in
the Philippines — and pull — in the form
of demand for cheap labor — produced an
explosion in Filipino migrant workers.
In 1960, 15% of all seafarers were Asian.
By 1987, that number had more than quadrupled
to 67%.
The next wave came from where the first originated:
the Middle East.
The Gulf States had grand visions for what
to do with their new wealth but no one willing
to actually build their underwater hotels
and giant empty picture frames.
…That’s where foreign labor comes in.
Today, 26% of Filipino migrants work in Saudi
Arabia, 14% in the UAE, 6 in Kuwait, and 5
in Qatar.
A significant portion of the rest work in
Hong Kong or Singapore as domestic helpers
— doing the laundry, childcare, cooking,
cleaning, and everything in-between for middle-class
households.
Some families even have two or three.
But this is really only half the answer to
our original question: why Filipinos came
to dominate these specific labor niches.
50 years ago the reason was, basically, coincidence
— timing, more than anything.
But even if the Philippines was the cheapest
source of labor in 1970, it hasn’t remained
that way for five consecutive decades.
What began as a “temporary response” to
a unique set of circumstances, in other words,
soon became a deliberate strategy.
The money workers send home — called ‘remittances’
— has grown from a nice side gig to a pillar
on which the entire national economy depends,
representing 10% of the country’s GDP.
At $35 billion US Dollars a year, remittances
could be considered the Philippines’ second-largest
export, just behind electronics, at $38 billion,
three times higher than third-place ‘machinery’,
and thirteen times larger than fourth-place
copper.
In the words of one former official, without
these overseas jobs reducing domestic unemployment,
there would be revolution.
And so, to sustain this flow of cash, the
Philippine government has become an unofficial
broker of labor.
When the President called herself the “CEO
of a global Philippine enterprise” in 2003,
she wasn’t kidding — the state functions,
in many ways, like a corporation — one whose
core business is selling one particular commodity
— labor.
Government departments travel to trade shows,
negotiate with foreign countries, and sometimes
even place labor directly.
It even does marketing — producing posters,
videos, and ads reinforcing the perception
of Filipinos as loyal, hard-working, and docile.
Yet, despite all this, quote, “the State
does not promote overseas employment as a
means to sustain economic growth and achieve
national development”.
The government, in other words, is uneasy
about its participation in what some have
called “legal human trafficking”.
It takes credit for the inflow of remittances
but no responsibility when workers are abused.
When they return home, workers are greeted
as “heroes”, not unlike members of the
military in America.
Sending money home is characterized as an
act of Nationalism, and each year the President
celebrates “Migrant Workers Day”.
But it’s not just the government reinforcing
this system.
You might think Filipino migrant workers would
aggressively fight back against these stereotypes
— and some do.
But many don’t see themselves as being exploited.
Despite high rates of abuse, harassment, and
harsh working conditions, overseas work is
often viewed in a positive light, as an opportunity.
…An opportunity that’s by no means guaranteed.
Many see themselves as competing with Indonesians,
Pakistanis, and Nepalese.
Reinforcing stereotypes, even about oneself,
is a powerful way of preserving these limited
opportunities.
But, more than anything else, what reinforces
this outflow of labor is economics.
Imagine that a bundle of cash ten or fifteen
times the average local wage fell out of the
sky and into every tenth house in your country,
each and every month.
Why would that lucky 10% of the population
look for a job?
Think about what kind of weird first, second,
and third-order effects this sudden airdrop
of cash would have on the economy.
Currency devaluation, inflation, lower real
incomes, and greater inequality between families
receiving and not receiving remittances.
The problem with treating labor as a resource,
in other words, is that it leads to the resource
curse.
What would these families buy with all that
money?
A new car, an extra room in the house, or
even an extra house.
Perhaps the most common purchase is a college
degree.
But this is not quite the escape from poverty
and investment in the nation’s future that
it may appear.
Remittances are directly responsible for the
education of millions of young Filipinos.
But they’re also responsible for the lack
of local demand for that very education.
The end goal of a college degree, very often,
is to immigrate — often as a nurse — to
the United States, in what has been called
“migrate to educate to migrate”
First, a mother, father, or both, go overseas
as domestic helpers or sailors, sending whatever
they can home to their children.
Those children are often expected to use that
money to train as nurses, immigrate to the
U.S., and take their turn sending remittances
home.
In 2015, more Filipino nurses were employed
abroad than passed the nursing board exams
at home.
Until the practice was banned, nursing students
were so desperate to acquire the experience
needed to go overseas that many paid hospitals
to allow them to work.
For the lucky few whose parents sacrificed
their labor abroad, who themselves studied
for years and years and years acquiring degrees,
and who have the incredible luck of entering
the labor market at the right moment, this
is a powerful pathway to a better life for
their families back home.
But think about what’s really happening
here: Individuals are expected to work overseas
just to pay for an education for the chance
of leaving, giving them the privilege of supporting
their families.
The state may take credit for this system,
but, for their families, these individual
moms, dads, uncles, and aunts are fulfilling
the role of the state — providing basic
things like food and education.
And because it relies on an immense amount
of hard-work, sacrifice, and luck, this is
not a sustainable, equitable process.
It can’t really be scaled or systematized
and it relies on an increasingly tenuous assumption:
that their labor and skills are appreciated
and welcome abroad.
All it takes is a change of visa rules in
a foreign country or a pandemic to nullify
all those years of sacrifice.
Last year, for instance, the Philippine government
capped the number of nurses allowed to work
overseas, forcing all but 5,000 to stay home,
risking their lives for very little money.
So, what do they do?
Many go back to school, in hopes that a second
or third-degree will make them more competitive.
According to one study, 39% of working Filipinos
are “overeducated” for their jobs.
Yet a quarter are “under-educated”.
This is just one more way the traditional
system of education fails students — by
preparing them for jobs that no longer exist.
Learning should be flexible, interesting,
and based on practical universal skills like
problem-solving, logic, and math — all things
which today’s sponsor, Brilliant, was designed
to be.
Brilliant has courses on everything from programming
to problem-solving, physics, and calculus.
What I like about Brilliant is that it makes
learning fun by focusing on applying knowledge
through interactive puzzles, riddles, and
games, not just by rote memorizing facts.
One trick I recently learned is to start your
day by doing something small but productive.
Doing a quick lesson on Brilliant in the morning
is a great way to instantly feel accomplished,
learn something new, and start your day on
the right foot.
Click the link on screen now and the first
200 people will get 20% off their annual premium
subscription.
You can even gift a subscription to a friend
or family member.
Go, pick what interests you most and start
learning today.